Welcome back everyone, Loki's assemble.
Like give us Avengers assemble.
But make it all Loki this is going to be my
new video about all these other brand-new
alternate versions of Loki that were seeing
during episode 5 Marvel just dropped a brand-new
clip with all these new alternate lokis, so
I'll explain what's going on here is a whole
bunch of Easter eggs as you would expect.
It's completely crazy.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'm also going to be doing marvel's what if
episodes.
Which you can start in August I'll be the
next big marvel Disney plus series in is crazy
as Loki is it's going to be even crazier with
multiverse concepts a spoiler warning for
all the Loki episodes so far if you have not
been watching the series during this new footage,
not including the four new lokis from the
post credit scene we just saw ever done a
video about them.
So all linkable in the description there are
10 new different versions of Loki with 11th
version from my last trailer video who doesn't
show up here.
So even though I'm I was he talking about
all these 10 Loki's here.
Like the Loki Army there yet even more lokis.
That we'll see during the episode.
But the way marvel's presenting this footage
this scene if you zoom and enhance on the
USS Eldridge footage, it actually seems like
this shot of all the Loki's here around President
Loki is happening on the USS Eldridge like
they're the ones that are firing stuff off
the bridge here.
They sort of clarify that all these of the
people that we've been seeing in the other
trailers around President Loki like we got
all the president Loki footage last year it's
been a long time's we've known about him for
a while but now, because were getting a good
look at all them are all meant to be versions
of Loki just some of them look very very different.
They kind of set that up back during episode
two when they were trying to foreshadow the
big Sylvie reveal the idea that not all Loki's
had to look like Tom Hiddleston think you
look vastly different some cases.
And a lot of them had different powers as
well.
We met a lot of battleworld secret wars comparisons
here.
Like if you read the recent Marvel secret
wars event.
This would be like the Loki version of the
Thor core, you just have a massive number
of alternate universe versions of the character
trying to work together.
But because it's a bunch of Loki's how much
they're working together is kind of a crap shoot
Like the initial group of four lokis that
we saw in episode four Post credit scene the
classic Loki, kid Loki, boastful Loki with
the Hammer and alligator Loki who I absolutely love
I can't wait to find out more about alligator
Loki all those Loki's are clearly there to
help our Loki right after he arrives.
So they're working together as a team like
a small unit of four lokis.
But then in this other footage inside President
Loki's layer you see boastful Loki beating
the hell out of this Isaac Hayes looking version
of Loki with the metal rimmed sunglasses,
the beads in the huge beard.
His crown of Loki horns seems like it's made
out a cloth, like a bandanna crown of horns.
Maybe they'll call him the burning man version
of Loki.
You can pick your metaphors here.
Like what is it that they're going for with
this vibe usually have to wait, we asked get
the credits to find out what the marvel people
that worked on the show call these different
versions which is clear that all the Loki's
are not as helpful and willing to work together
as other Loki's but he that's the whole idea
the show.
Owen Wilson's Mobius character has that speech
inside the time prison after our Loki had
his nuts kicked in a billion times by step
in he says you can be anything you want to be
You can even be a good person.
In stark contrast to his reputation for mischief
and chaos.
So all these many other Loki variants on this
trash planet are like the full spectrum of
be whoever you want to be.
From good, to bad to worse.
Like President Loki seems like he's the maximum
mischief power hungry Loki.
Like another version of Loki from the events
of the first Thor movie or after Thor the
dark world when he steals the throne pretending
to be Odin.
President Loki is actually straight out of
the comics.
Some of these new Loki's are big comic book
Easter eggs and references.
But some of them seem like they're just meant
to be extremely different or ridiculous versions.
Just to pay off the concept of the TVA pruning
timelines where variants are way too different
from what they consider to be normal for the
sacred timeline.
Even though we got that full reveal that the
time keepers were fake their like animatronic
robots been controlled by someone else who
will probably find out about by the end of
episode five before that big reveal.
They actually speak to our Loki and Sylvie
saying that there cosmic disappointments so
I think that's the idea with these other Loki's
there pruning and sending to this planet is
that whoever's really behind the TVA the time
keepers is pruning timelines that they deemed
to be cosmic disappointments like you're not
within the range of what we consider an appropriate
version of Loki.
So were going to prune you which is also why
they probably tried to prune Sylvie, but she
wound up escaping otherwise.
It's implied she would've also been sent to
this planet.
But going left to right here through the Loki
Army there's a version wearing a green shroud
with goggles and tattoos all call him mad
Max Loki.
Loki beyond the ThunderDome.
But to be honest, because the post apocalyptic
vibe this whole planet is giving off with
the ruins of all these pruned buildings like
the avengers tower, everything here, all these
versions of Loki are kind of giving off mad
max vibes next to him there's a Loki, with
a torn military jacket and a mask covering
his face and horns made of Bones of some kind
next to him as a Loki in a pilot's suit with
a makeshift morning star weapon with a bunch
of nails, and a helmet with giant bike handlebars
on top that is some epic DIY Loki their he's
also wearing a president Loki pin, some of
these lokis are wearing president Loki pins.
So as I theorized earlier.
It seems like President Loki is trying to
win over his own faction of Loki's on this planet
And they don't see everyone wearing pins here,
I'm assuming that these other nine lokis around
President Loki here are his followers and
I do love the idea that despite this apocalypse
that they're living in here.
President Loki is still trying to rule over
the planet is you seems like some of these
other Loki's are less intelligent like they
take his bait like is listen to whatever it
is that he tells them to do that also kind
of gets into the whole idea of the superior
Loki in the multiverse the one who is most
cunning, most successful the most fully realized version
Mobius kinda made it sound like the TVA at
least the beginning of the show considered
that to be Sylvie like she was the superior
Loki because she was the most dangerous one,
the one that they weren't able to capture.
But part of him explaining that was him trying
to goad our Loki into helping him out helping catch her
So whether or not he was speaking the truth
whether or not they really think that she's
the superior Loki remains to be seen behind
helmet Loki here there's an old Man Loki looking
version with really long gray hair and robes
he doesn't have any horns on his head.
He looks kind of like a Denethor version of
Loki from lord of the rings.
Like all the Loki's aren't meant to be the
same age as evidenced by Richard E Grant's
classic Loki and Jack veal's kid Loki.
Some of them are really old versions.
Some of them are really young versions that
on the left of President Loki here there's
another one, that's wearing a military helmet
with small horns embedded in it in another
military uniform.
There's actually a lot of Loki's here with
repurposed military gear and I know a lot
of you have asked, if the TVA arrested these
Loki's and processed them, then erased them
which now we know didn't actually erase them.
It just sent them to this planet.
How do all of them have their costumes if
everyone they arrest gets put in prison jumpsuits
when they're arrested my guess is that when
these versions all wound up here.
Like including classic Loki in his really
old school looking Jack Kirby costume which is amazing
Because so many other buildings, objects like
the USS Eldridge everything.
Military ships, weapons anything you can imagine
get sent here.
These lokis all the ones they get sent here
just scavenge supplies from whatever shows
up day to day, and that's how they make all
these costumes really good example.
This is President Loki's throne room here.
Like it looks kind of crazy with all these
different objects in here, you see the Polybius
arcade machine in the background which itself
is a cool real life Easter egg.
For big video game history fans.
Which is the idea that all manner of items
get sent here when the TVA reset timelines
with their devices.
If you're not familiar with Polybius is an
urban legend that started in the early 2000's
about this fictitious 1980s arcade game the
urban legend goes that the game was part of
this government run crowd source like a logical
experiment based in Portland, Oregon, during
1981 in the gameplay was supposed to produce
these intense psychoactive and addictive effects
in players with a bunch of men in black visiting
different versions of the arcade machine to
collect all this data then allegedly, all
the arcade machines disappeared before people
in the early 2000's could go track them down
the be a lot of funny Easter eggs like that
in the background of this episode on this
trash planet.
So just keep your eyes peeled but then you
have President Loki who most of you recognize
from the comics.
He's from the vote Loki marvel story that
published in 2016 which itself was meant to
be a parody of the real world 2016 United
States election a version of Loki tries to
lie and cheat his way into the White House
during that election in a daily bugle reporter
tries to expose his lies.
It only lasted for four issues so wasn't huge
story, it was more just a one off joke capitalizing
on the craziness of the election that year.
But next to him on the right is a dumber looking
wool hat Loki, with spikes instead of horns in it
He seems like a bit thicker Loki.
Mentally thick and physically thick.
And he's also got the vote Loki pin on his
hat.
Which makes him look even less intelligent
on his right seems like another female Loki
with red hair this been died some kind of
visor instead of horns on her head and she's
got a makeshift meteor Hammer weapon with
the ball and chain.
If you saw Kill Bill volume one is kind like
Gogo's weapon.
You also notice she's wearing what seems like
a striped prison looking uniform.
Like she's stolen someone else's striped prison
jumpsuit which is gray.
Because you know all the TVA jumpsuits are
tan and orange next her on the right is that
Isaac Hayes looking Loki I Morty talked about
the one is getting his ass kicked by boastful
Loki in the other trailer footage the next
to him is an Asian looking version of Loki
with football pads that he's using as armor,
large shades covering his face.
Some gold chains and he's also got a vote
Loki pin on him.
Like I said, just hammering home the idea
that President Loki has built his own faction
of Loki's on this battleworld scenario.
It would be funny if Richard E Grant's classic
Loki was referencing these versions when he
told our Loki come with us or you will be
dead soon.
Like these other Loki's might wind up killing
him.
Which seems like a very Loki thing to do like
Loki is the god of mischief, he's an agent
of chaos in most realities of course with
a bunch of them getting dumped here on the regular
You have a full on battleworld secret wars
scenario where they've gone battle royale,
but it's only alternate universe versions
of him.
This whole concept of all of these lokis getting
sent here from different timelines makes you
wonder if the TVA, when they reset things
with their devices they send all the Loki's here
Where do they send everyone else.
Like is there a pocket universe world like
this for each unique person that they prune
or are they really completely erasing some
things for real like miss minutes and the
other hunters said that they were the only
other new version of Loki that we know about
from the trailers who doesn't appear here
in this trailer is King Loki in a new version of asgard
Inside Odin's throne room.
It's not clear if that's also happening on
this planet orifice from a separate scene
somewhere else.
Because his costume seems very similar to
Loki's costume from the first Thor movie.
So either he's also on this planet where it
seems like most of the events of episode 5
Take Pl. or they travel somewhere else briefly
during the episode for some reason is also
the very dark Asgard looking black citadel
here that our Loki is looking at in enters
very evil very ominous looking.
So that might be where we get a big villain
reveal in possibly yet another alternate Loki reveal
Because this architecture does seem kind of
asgardian inspired.
So far the only thing we haven't really seen
on the show yet, is a very very evil version
of Loki was only scene the mischievous versions
of Loki, troublesome lokis.
But none that you could call evil.
Loki had the whole speech about no one ever
being truly evil.
So I do wonder if we'll meet someone before
the end of the show who is very evil let me
know in the comments though who is your favorite
new alternate version of Loki from this planet.
And do you think they'll reveal the real main
villain by the end of the episode my full
Loki episode 5 video will post Wednesday morning
just like normal.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for all my full Loki episode videos and
click here for my Loki Post credit scene video and easter eggs
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!